et nous sommes en direct avec emmanuel
dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france servait
lavrov se dit donc prêt à discuter avec
lyon et reims l'union européenne et la
france notamment
réponse finalement emmanuel macron qui
prône le dialogue avec moscou
oui alors c'est une réponse d'une
certaine manière biaisée puisque le
président mails macron a eu des mots
aigres-doux si j'ose dire à l'égard de
la russie d'ailleurs l'intervention des
ménages macron a précédé celle de
sergueï lavrov où il a évoqué la
nécessité d'ouvrir le dialogue avec
moscou tout en mettant en garde les
possibilités ou la capacité tasse à 32
pays et il évoquer nommément la russie
je suis de déstabiliser les démocraties
occidentales donc un discours que le
président français a tenu ambivalent
d'une certaine manière la 56e édition de
la conférence de sécurité de munich est
en transition
ce fut longtemps le lieu où s'expriment
et une voix transatlantique où le
dialogue euro atlantique prenait force
et vigueur si j'ose dire et cette
édition est d'une certaine manière
l'objet d'une transition on a évoqué la
perte d'influencé pouvoir la perte de
confiance des valeurs occidentales
en ce qui concerne les crises
internationales l'incapacité ou
l'insuffisante mobilisation des acteurs
traditionnels au sein du conseil de
sécurité pour éviter les crises et
l'émergence de nouvelles formes
alternatives de médiation et c'est la
raison pour laquelle la prise de parole
du ministère étrangères sergueï lavrov
était importante au même titre que celle
du ministre des affaires étrangères
iranien pour rappeler que sur un certain
nombre de crises la libye la syrie et
l'iran la crise dans le golfe
les acteurs étaient plus nombreux
qu'auparavant et qu' il fallait
effectivement comme l'ont rappelé
l'ensemble des intervenants la trentaine
de chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui
était présent ouvrir davantage un
dialogue stratégique avec davantage de
partenaires
elle a réussi se dit donc prête à
collaborer davantage sur l'agenda
international quelles conséquences
possibles sur les dossiers en cours tels
que
la série la libye très concrètement bah
écoute et déjà le président mm macro et
le mil affaires étrangères russe sergueï
lavrov ont évoqué la tenue en avril
prochain à berlin de la deuxième édition
du format normandie pour le dialogue sur
l'ukraine donc c'est un élément concret
pour lesquels il ya convergence
il ya un autre élément qui a été évoqué
le président le pardon le président
russe oui vadimir poutine l'avait évoqué
il ya quelques semaines à jérusalem à
l'occasion du 75e anniversaire de la
libération du camp d'auschwitz d'une
réunion tout à fait innovante si j'ose
dire et une régulière en tout cas
souffle pour lesquels il appelait de ses
voeux une mobilisation des cinq membres
du conseil de sécurité qu'il pourrait se
réunir sous un format qui aurait
vocation à être pérennisées donc on voit
bien qu'il ya sur un certain nombre de
dossiers
une volonté d'associer l'ensemble de du
des membres du conseil de sécurité vers
davantage de cohésion est l'exemple de
ce qui se passe actuellement en syrie
arrive libre ou l'incapacité à trouver
une issue pour étayer le cessez le feu
est donc à trèves ayant vocation à se
transformer en cessez-le-feu en libye
impact effectivement sur la nécessité
d'associer beaucoup plus de partenaires
dans la résolution de ces deux conflits
au moins on pourrait ajouter évidemment
l'afghanistan puisqu'il en fut question
à l'occasion de cette conférence puisque
les américains ont annoncé par la voix
de mike pompéo qu'ils étaient tout
proche d'un accord avec les talibans
à moins peut-être de l'otan sanei lavrov
a dit espérer que les propos d' emmanuel
macron sur la nécessité d'un dialogue
avec la russie feront leur chemin dans
le cerveau de l'otan je le cite à nos
collègues de l'otan lorsqu'il déclare
qu'ils sont prêts à dialoguer avec la
russie trish ils sont ouverts à un
dialogue qu'il considère uniquement
comme des critiques à notre rôle à notre
égard
quel peut-être l'influencent d' emmanuel
macron sur ses partenaires de l'otan
vis-à-vis de la russie
ecoutez-le influence des macros se
départir de l'otan est particulièrement
limitée et l'expérience des dernières
semaines ou des derniers mois où
l'évolution de la pensée du président
français à l'égard de l'otan en témoigne
le président et macron et ça a été
rappelé par segueï lavrov a engagé une
voix ardue mais je pense utile pour un
dialogue constructif avec moscou inutile
de préciser que l'ensemble des
partenaires les 29 autres membres de
l'otan ne sont pas forcément au diapason
sur cette position
ça a été rappelé lors du sommet
anniversaire de londres le du 3 et 4
décembre dernier ça a été rappelé durant
les dernières heures à l'occasion de la
conférence de munich notamment par la
voix du secrétaire d'état américain mike
pompéo qui ne s'est pas montré tout à
fait ouvert à cette critique de l'otan
rappelant au contraire que le temps
était particulièrement alerte et qu'il
fallait la renforcer notamment sur son
pilier orientale le président mm macro
ne cesse d'appeler à une dialogue
stratégique avec moscou et dans le même
temps on apprend que des troupes
françaises vont venir renforcer la
protection et la sûreté et la lâchera
pas la police de l'air dans les pays
dans les états baltes donc d'une
certaine manière la critique selon
laquelle l'otan se rapprochent arrêt des
frontières de la russie est
particulièrement peut-être bienvenue
encore une fois avec cette forme
peut-être qu'ils offrez nick d'appeler
un dialogue stratégique avec l'otan avec
la russie pardon et voulant entraîné les
partenaires de l'otan avec une fin de
non recevoir de ses partenaires
notamment ceux qui s'estiment les plus
en péril ou en tout cas qui
s'estimeraient les plus en porte-à-faux
avec
vous avez de la russie notamment les
pays de l' or de son voisinage le je
pense notamment la pologne ou à la
roumanie
merci beaucoup pour votre analyse
emmanuel dupuy président de l'institut
prospective et sécurité